you know what I did I decided to
apologize
I decided to apologize and see would the
people be happy oh I put her in the
primaries you're going to General
she spends this entire time
do I think she's a Drifter absolutely
yeah
and this is why guys never apologize to
the Mob because they don't want your
apology they don't care about you and
they just want to see if they can
control you
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
selective Outreach so today I'm going to
be talking about how the internet gets
selectively outraged so um if you guys
are familiar with the fresh and fit in
Abba and preach videos Myron maybe like
a year ago now he had a video go viral
and I mean stupid viral of him insulting
preach's wife
I've been preacher another YouTube
channel and they do reaction videos this
is a preacher's married prior to a
[__] Beluga somewhere starting [__]
at first glance you might think that
Myron is crazy I mean why is this man
insulting insulting preach's wife and
when they do the reaction videos they
really don't tell the full story and
that's what I wanted to talk about today
is a lot of times what you see with
these reaction channels is they take a
clip of a full conversation and a lot of
reaction channels are looking for Clips
to take you out of context and not give
the full story and they are lying to you
now let's talk about fresh and fit so
admin preach went on fresh and fits
podcast and I think as a podcast host
when you have other YouTubers and you
you try to treat them cordially you
bring them into your studio you
introduce them to your staff you you
usually a lot of times you might be
hanging out before hanging out after and
you feel like you're at least friendly
like friends with these people and what
happened was a couple weeks later Ava
and preached it a hit piece on Myron and
the way they did it was kind of sneaky
like they said that you know we were
just attacking ideas paying for box and
then went on dates then found out she's
on the sugar baby site then when it
comes out that she's on seeking
arrangements then he actually looks like
live stream where he's like no we met on
seeking like everything is smoking
mirrors right
which is fine at the end of the day if
you want to sell an image and you got a
lie to do it do it like which ones that
they should use or whatever so like
these are the ones you guys got to be
using all right you got to be using
Tinder you got to be using Bumble you
got to be using hinge you got to be
using um if you live in a Latin based
City like we live in Miami so chespa is
good here you know what I'm saying which
is a Spanish joint
um you know which it's more like for
Latinos
um I don't like Plenty of Fish but I've
heard some people use it with with
um with some success and then you got
Okay Cupid as well but the point is is
that you just need to have multiple
fishing rods in the ocean you know what
I'm saying because like I said this is
definitely a numbers game
um I got a homeboy
cleans up on Plenty of Fish yeah you
just probably listen to this right now
and you'll be selling with the lowest or
the low but he does it man I don't know
yeah you know you could definitely clean
up on these apps and then you got
seeking Arrangement which is like a
sugar daddy site but like that that's a
whole other we'll probably have to do a
video on that the slimy thing was they
were like passive aggressively insulting
the man and and men just don't respond
Bond well to that like you you bring
someone into your studio you treat them
well then they leave and do a whole hit
piece on you saying that you're capping
so you don't get girls like that like I
think anyone normal can see how that's
disrespect
problem that we get into it's that
nobody cares about what's true because
you know 10 million people saw Myron
freaking out but nobody saw his
explanation in a stream that gets 150
000 views and that's that's the problem
with the culture today is you can paint
an entire narrative about somebody and
it not be true you know it wasn't like
Myron insulted his wife out of out of
thin air Myron felt disrespected and you
know I don't agree with insulting
someone's wife I think that's quite rude
you know personally with the internet
for the most part I've learned to just
ignore stuff but at a certain point you
you want to defend yourself and a lot of
times what these reaction channels do is
they take clip clip clip clip clip they
paint a narrative and they don't tell
the full story and a lot of times these
reaction channels haven't even done the
research to make a full conclusion on
the story my point to the audience is
that this is dishonest they are lying to
you and they don't care about the truth
they care about clicks and Views so the
last couple of days oh my gosh [__] has
been so stressful so I had a hit piece
go out on me from you know the quote
unquote the black manosphere and the
black manosphere is a very pro-black
part of YouTube and I can't acknowledge
that I would say you know some of the
black manosphere is part of my audience
and what happened this week was they
pulled eclipse from an interview I had
with Nick Fuentes now a lot of these men
have been making hit pieces on me for
months for months they have been saying
oh you shouldn't listen to this girl
this is your new leader she's this this
they would just make up all the stuff so
they have just been waiting for me to
slip up and say something that they can
construe as because I'm a woman you
can't pull me as sexist so you know
personally I follow I follow things that
interest me I always just do what I'm
interested in and I heard about this guy
named Nick Fuentes who who is a far
extremist he has been banned on
everything even his bank account I
invited him on he offered to fly himself
here now
during this interview we touched on the
topic of slavery and what these reactors
did is they were trying to make me look
racist by pulling Clips I said out of
context now I mentioned in this
interview that all of these thoughts
were from Thomas Sowell I read Soul so
he talks about
is gonna get me in trouble how slavery
was a global institution and the word
slave actually came from Slavic which is
white wherever a separate people were
enslaved they were disdained or despised
whether they were different by country
religion caste race or tribe
the Europeans were enslaved in North
Africa were despised and abused because
they were Christians in a Muslim region
of the world where they were called
Christian dogs
race became the most visible difference
between slaves and slave owners in the
Western Hemisphere
as distinguished historian Daniel J
borsten put it now for the first time in
Western history the status of slave
coincided with a difference of race
to make racism the driving force behind
slavery is to make a historically recent
Factor the cause of an institution which
originated thousands of years earlier
this enshrinement of racism as an
overarching causal Factor Accords far
more with current instrumental agendas
than with history
a guy that's written like 80 books on
this topic and now you can agree with
Thomas so well you can disagree with
Thomas Sowell and you could even say
maybe I didn't use the correct words but
that doesn't make me a person but the
problem is all of these reactors are
just sitting there waiting for you to
slip up and to paint a narrative about
you and that's what I've seen people do
to fresh and fit for the past three
years my my whole point is that these
reaction channels are just sitting there
looking for you to say the wrong thing
they're looking for you to slip up and
they're not going to things in good
faith and the other issue you get with
content creators especially reaction
channels is they turn on you in a dime
and that's what Adam preached to fresh
and fit they're hanging out in the
studio and the next week they're saying
oh you're capping you're capping you're
capping and you know ab and preach
proceed to make like 20 videos on them
and fresh and fit didn't say anything
now guys you know anyone I I don't even
think I've worked with fresh and Finn in
like two years
um
I'm not even saying this to defend them
but I just see what the reaction
channels are doing it's like a system
and they want to paint content creators
a certain way they want to make sneako
look stupid they want fresh and fit to
look sexist and racist they want and now
they've come for me they want me to look
and there was a guy named Rolo tabassi
and Rolo tomasi was
um a guy in the red pill space and at
one point I really wanted him to Mentor
me but he said it's not personal but I
can't associate with your brand and I
didn't really understand what he meant
at the time but what these reaction
channels will do is if you have a
controversial person on your platform
they will start to insinuate that you
believe what they believe and they'll
look for a video of you saying yes you
joking with that person you just being
polite to that person and paint a
narrative about you being racist about
you being sexist about you being
homophobic whatever narrative they want
to push with Rollo I didn't understand
what he meant at the time but now I do
the issue is if you associate with
certain people and me coming into the
space I'm like I'll talk to anyone
what's the big deal I mean I'm bringing
randoms to my studio every night like
who cares but the issue you get into is
the reaction channels they're they're
like vultures well they'll come in and
try to make you look a certain way and
try to make you paint a certain way
paint it be painted a certain way for
clicks and Views even if they know damn
well you're not that way back to Nick
Fuentes I did a podcast with this man
named Nick Fuentes and Nick Fuentes
again extremist he doesn't believe in
race mixing does it believe in that like
thinks that was over exaggerated and
we're talking about the idea of people
using an atrocity to control you and if
you listen to it like 20 minutes around
where we started talking about slavery
you will see the context but the
reaction channels either don't want to
see the context or they're too lazy
because they're afraid of Their audience
because if they watch the full video but
most of their audience has seen the one
minute clip they can't go against Their
audience that's that's the problem is
now we get to a point where it doesn't
even matter what's true or what's false
it literally doesn't matter because you
know the reaction channels can make a
million view video about me or make a
you know 10 million view Tick Tock about
me even if they know that that's not
true and how often do the reaction
channels come up come back and say you
know what we effed up you know what we
painted a false narrative you know what
and they never do because what incentive
did they have to do that because then
Their audience wouldn't trust them one
thing they said that I said was that I
was comparing black Americans to African
Americans now one I didn't even know
about this animosity towards the two but
I was simply just commenting how much I
love my employees
how how hard they work how great they
are and these reaction channels were
trying to say that I was trying to put
down someone else you know non
non-western people come in with the
hunger that a lot of times you know
westerners were spoiled and I never
mentioned race but these people are
trying to make it about race and saying
oh that's what she really meant that's
what she really said but it wasn't what
I said and they're putting words into my
mouth and these people they're bullies I
was joking around I was joking around
with with Nick Fuentes and they said oh
you can't you can't joke around with him
sorry that's my personality I joke
around with anyone you didn't offer him
enough pushback well sorry I listened to
understand what they're saying it
doesn't mean I agree and that's the
thing with these reaction channels will
do they'll look for a clip of you or or
One Clip will go viral of you and
they're so scared of Their audience that
they won't tell you the truth they won't
tell you the context they don't want to
even know the context because they're
going to go against Their audience but
here I'm going to tell you guys the
truth no matter what do you think this
is going to help me this video telling
you guys the the behind the scenes of
this hell no but to me if these people
are lying on me I I'm sorry I gotta tell
the truth so blessing my my producer who
I speak so highly of
I I speak so highly of he he was late
and you know I said African time
and you know what they're they're going
to clip this they're going to say I did
this did that and I'm I'm a white Apollo
blah blah blah and you know what what
they don't know is I was referring to
something blessing said earlier that's
something he says when he walks in the
door and all of these reaction channels
are gonna come in and say oh oh Pearl
shouldn't do that in front of a white
supremacist that's so disrespectful well
if my employees were disrespected that's
their job to talk to me to be honest I
can go on to even say that Nick is a was
in terms of the guests that we've had so
far quiet a nice guy he didn't carry any
ego
he just says you know views that he
wasn't threatening we might not agree I
think I think we put him on the spot
none of them had a problem I even had
one of my producers take a picture with
him you know and this is the problem is
the reaction channels none of them
actually reached out to my employees to
see how they're doing to see if they're
okay where if they were really outraged
about if they really cared they would do
that they also cut out a part where Nick
made a joke and said he was kidding I
text you I'm on my way because I thought
I was already 10 minutes late when I was
leaving
he's black
[Laughter]
they didn't put in the full clip that
said he said oh I'm just giving you a
hard time I'm kidding why would they cut
that out
why would they do that the other thing
they put in was that my friend and Nick
Fuentes were going back and forth about
interracial dating and that I should
have spoken more I should have spoken up
if Gabby needed help if Gabby was
holding her own she was holding her own
if she needed help then I certainly
would have helped but I know the girl
and
she was holding her own just fine so now
let's get into mtr's reaction so MTR
media I want to give you guys a little
background into my relationship with MTR
if you don't know
half a million subscribers mediocre
tutorials and reviews I met him when I
was in Miami and I actually spent a good
amount of time with him he flew in for a
one-on-one interview and he actually
spent a day with me and my sister like
honestly I I felt like I actually opened
up to him in a way because I let him
meet my family
um you know I mean that any YouTuber
knows we always want to protect our
family from the public and you know I I
introduced him to my sister you
knowingly invited
a white supremacist and a
self-proclaimed racism I have no problem
inviting people that disagree I have no
problem
having crazy conversations I will not
apologize for having a controversial
guess because I will keep having
controversial guests my staff is very
aware of this they know this and if they
have an issue with this they should talk
to me not the internet and that's that's
the other thing about YouTubers is why
the hell are YouTubers that have my
number going to the internet before they
talk to me a lot of these YouTubers are
so scared to protect their brand that
they will throw anyone and everyone
under the bus and it's honestly
Bloodsport and it's honestly disgusting
Pearl you know that your staff is mostly
black people and I'm talking about from
a production perspective as well as a
talent perspective MTR if you are
worried about my employees why didn't
you message blessing why didn't you
message King why didn't you message
Helen you certainly could have reached
out to them you certainly could have
asked me for their numbers but you chose
to go to the Internet because you were
offended for my employees I don't think
that your platform would be as big as
what it is today if it wasn't for the
essential utilization of black people
black relationship topics
and black talent I don't know how
said this and
I have to keep saying this my my
platform
how could I have a
about black issue
if I talk about relationships my last
shows up the two that come to my head
why can't we call a ho ho
trust me there are hoes in every color
oh my God trust me and how to be a good
wife what's a good wife they go off the
titles and they don't even watch it and
then they make a reaction video saying
that I said something I didn't or my
show's about something it's not you know
I'm not going to say we've never touched
on a black Topic in a year of shows but
[__] in terms of how often it's really
not and that's it why why wouldn't he go
through the shows why wouldn't he do his
due diligence when he he spent time with
me he's met me and we had a great
relationship up until he made this hit
piece and the other accusation he had
you could have had black people in the
same room we did we did a whole panel
with black people in their black I mean
it was a mix of races but we certainly
had black people there too so again it's
all of these reaction channels saying
this is how you should run the show but
none of them have done it none of them
are that successful and
they want to tell us how to run our
shows and the other thing you know what
an MTR here's the thing I am really not
about bringing out private things behind
the scenes to public I think it's trashy
but if you're gonna publicly accuse me
of things and you're gonna publicly make
a hit piece on me then I have to
publicly defend myself now what's crazy
is that I came across these comments
while I was live streaming a couple of
days ago and what you found out on live
is about the clips is just not true you
know it's not true I don't know why
you're lying to your audience General
and not once in the interview did you
have at least one pro-black stance MTR
you said yourself before you released
the video when I asked you did you watch
the full interview
you said no so how do you even know
because that's the thing he doesn't care
he doesn't care what's right he doesn't
care what's true he cares about
appeasing his audience and that's what
all these reaction channels are doing to
you and along with my accountability
this is now my definitive stance I can
no longer support or associate myself
with the just pearly things
platform MTR if you don't want to wear
work with me I fully support that you
don't want to associate with me I fully
support that why are you still making
money off of the clips from the show on
my channel I'm so offensive you better
take those off because now I certainly
don't give you permission to use those
because why would I you don't want to
associate with the brand so take them
off stop stop making money off of them
and that's what these people do they're
absolute Hypocrites I've also have a no
beef policy
on my platform you have a no beef policy
on my platform but you make a hit piece
on me and this is what he's going to do
because this is what the reaction
channels do they never apologize and
they just double down then you know what
he's going to do he's going to find
another clip take it out of context and
then say Oh no well now that I've
watched the full interview and this is
the principle it's not even that he may
have been offended it's that we are
grown adults and you could call me
and yet you choose to go to the Internet
first now I don't know where where was
honor where was respect and where was
dignity if someone has been kind enough
to allow me into their Studio to you
know I even introduced you to my family
to spend days shooting content with you
and then you turn around and say you
can't associate with the with the
network what is courageous to make a hit
piece on me to appease your audience
what's more courageous to do that or two
go with the narrative what everyone's
saying and you know what you might not
say it today you might not say it
tomorrow but you are absolutely wrong
for this you were absolutely wrong you
quote unquote left the manosphere but
you're still in it and okay and let's
talk about defamation of character so
this is the thumbnail that MTR put of me
he said in quotes that an insinuating
that I said that slavery was not that
bad I did not say that and in fact in
the clip I said that it was horrible
they the founder of or the guy who made
root said I wanted a myth for my people
to live by so they often but that's what
they do is they embellish and I'm not
trying to say it wasn't horrible it was
right but they want to make it like more
horrible
so that they can control people in a way
how is it not defamation of character to
say that I said something I didn't say
in the thumbnail you know and it's one
thing when you do that to someone random
or whatever but you know and these
Random clips that circulate on YouTube
but I work on YouTube that's my
livelihood
and it's funny because they act like
they care about black issues but yet
they're trying to damage the reputation
of a a network that hires majority black
employees and without even asking the
employees are they offended how did they
take it and so that's what I'm saying
these content creators get outraged for
for my employees who are not mad I
didn't even hear about it till after he
left and everyone's gonna say oh they're
secretly offended they just couldn't
tell you and that's how I know nobody
stepped a foot in my studio because they
absolutely will tell me if they agree if
they don't agree but they all know
signing up to work here we have
controversial guests let's talk about
that let's talk about the thumbnail
you're also that's not legal either it's
defamation of character just put in
quotes and insinuate I said something I
didn't say I said in that exact clip
that you saw you watched you reacted to
it wasn't that horrible and when I asked
you why would you put that I said
something I didn't say well it's how the
comments interpreted it and that's not
what I meant and you know it's not what
I meant and that's the worst part is he
knows I'm not a racist he knows he knows
all of this stuff and I I beg you MTR
name one instance we had where I treated
any of my employees unfairly where I was
rude to any of my employees where I was
rude to you where I was rude to any of
our mutual friends and you know what in
hindsight I probably would have put out
a statement saying he had nothing to do
with the Nick Fuentes interview and I
would have been happy to do that if he
asked me but he didn't ask me and you
know when you're being called by
everyone in the book and then your
friend tries to pile on and again all of
the ideas that I spoke about were from
Thomas Sowell a author of 80 books on
the topic so you could say maybe as a
white woman I shouldn't have said
anything about it but I certainly was
quoting someone else and that's the
crazy thing oh my gosh
so what did I do I decided why don't I
put out an apology video just as a test
I wanted to see would the mob be happy
no they never accept your apology and
did MTR backtrack and say you know what
given that I have spent this much time
with her I was more than willing to work
with her before I had no issues before
but now when the Crowd Goes one way I'm
gonna go with it now let's let's show
another clip that could be taken out of
context and make it look like this man
is racist against white people what are
we doing to white people and I was going
to say erasing them which I agree we are
you know with every interracial
relationship you know I mean white
people we're immigrating they're not
having babies we're racing oh that's
where it's gonna go we're not erasing
them I thought the Chinese guy was
getting there you know what we doing we
bring in our people we take it over
right and I was going to celebrate it we
was about to celebrate it
yeah the future
but it is white people's fault what is
everything what are we doing to white
people
I don't know taking the skin and wearing
it but you know
you know I know the kind
of the cons kidding
a lot of these reaction channels do they
wait for you to slip up O'Shea claims to
support the black community yet he
constantly goes after organizations that
support black content creators how can
you say you're pro-black when you know
honestly between me and fresh and fit we
employ more black people than you do so
after the apology video I said okay
let's see let's see how Brave these men
are so I I asked obsidian to host a
debate and I said everyone that has had
so much to say about me come on the
stream nobody showed up
it I'm a firm believer that if you truly
believe something about someone you
should be able to say it to their face
and all you boys couldn't even show up
to a stream and you know what if if I
was this Die Hard race that they think
why didn't they show up you should want
to tell off a rate tell me how horrible
I am how could you spend hours and hours
and hours listening to me talk but you
can't stand by what you said and this is
the thing about these reaction channels
what's what's Courageous Courageous is
going against the mob and honestly a lot
of these reactors are no better than the
feminists that paint a narrative about
men a lot of feminists you know they
might take a clip or take a snippet of a
story and say he did this he did that
he's this and these goddamn content
creators do the same thing and you could
say what I said was inaccurate maybe
insensitive but to say you question my
morals are you kidding me and that's the
thing we live in this Society where we
no longer can give people the benefit of
the doubt and that's the worst part is
that MTR didn't even watch the full
video even though he met my sister he
spent a bunch of time with me he came
over to see me in London we shot so much
content for him he still couldn't even
give me the benefit of the doubt and
felt like he needed to cater to his
audience do you know who I respect I
respect the content creators that
doubled down because they knew me Anton
Daniels oh he got a lot of pushback for
defending the obsidian he got a lot of
pushback for defending me she she's
cool with me I wouldn't call her a
friend but it is definitely a person uh
that I've had multiple different
conversations to she's added value into
my life behind the scenes gave me some
game uh I gave her hopefully
reciprocated and gave her some game we
didn't kicked it in person she'd have
met my wife but they know me in real
life so they know I've been nothing but
polite they know that I I do my best to
be friendly and kind to people and they
refused to profit off of me and I'm not
trying to paint myself as a victim I do
very well on YouTube you guys you guys
aren't going to to stop me you're not
really going to bring me down MTR says
he's against cancer culture and he
accuses brands of bending to the will of
the woke ma but what did you just do I'm
not mad
I'm disappointed
and I'm gonna remain professional
but it just bothers me that companies
still will Buckle to the whim
of this [__] now you guys see the
uphill battle in real time that I have
to climb that the content creators in
this space have to climb we've set a
whole bunch of first in here one of the
four first is actually having Brands and
sponsorship that come down in here and
show us respect and at the drop of of a
Thanos click
a Thanos snap
they take it away why because the
victims come out the woodwork and say
he's misogynistic the weaponized term
that has nothing to do with my channel
has nothing to do with my channel and
you know it
I'm disappointed but it shows the uphill
uh battle that we have to climb because
cannot tell me that you did that in good
faith what happened to good faith you
did that to protect your brand and to
build your audience and you know what if
that's how you want to play it go do it
but you know a lot of people can see
through this [__]
and the truth always comes out so you
spoke about that but this is the same
way you're bending to the will of your
audience if you don't go on stream and
say that you think I'm go on stream and
say that you think that you question my
morals select correctly or if you let
someone into your proverbial Inner
Circle
um before that they have been properly
vetted these are the people that can
bring you down into the abyss as well oh
oh
you're right you're right that I could
see how that would happen and you know
what the worst part is this goddamn
thumbnail because he knows I messaged
him did I say that he knows I didn't say
that and that's the thing if he's
willing to do this to me I would say he
was an acquaintance maybe a friend all
right if he was willing to do that to me
what's he willing to do to you just keep
this in mind as you are
creating friendships throughout your
life is that
when everything is going good
it's high time for your acquaintances
but when things
are not so good
the acquaintances will slowly shift to
the back
oh
well well well how is it not snake
Behavior to insinuate
that I have missed and have bad morals
after I allowed you onto my platform
after I paid for so much footage to be
edited cut also I'd like to add you
um disrespectfully made a video about me
you disrespectfully put something in the
thumbnail and defamed my character and
said I said something that I did not say
and you you pretended to be concerned
about my employees but you didn't even
reach out to them and you know what you
know what I'm gonna disrespectfully post
all of the footage that we took because
you know what honestly that footage was
fire and I'm making money off of it and
no you do not have permission to use any
Clips on your channel you know and I
will you know MTR MTR I'll give you I'll
give you I'll give you a video I already
know how the reaction channels do it so
I'm sure he's just gonna Double Down
find another clip that Pearl looks like
is an ill will Pearl looks bad and you
know I'm sure he's gonna find something
else to make me paint me in a certain
light and you know what that was a
pretty controversial conversation so I'm
sure he's gonna find it and you know
what you know what I'll give you I'll
give you a chance you can come if you
you admit you messed up maybe we can
repair this
no no not not right now not right now
and that's what honestly all these
reaction channels do they just pull
clips and like they're looking for it
and guys you're gonna start to see it
after some point also MTR I'm asking
that you take down all videos of us
together on your channel because
um you don't want to be associated with
my platform so I'm giving you the
opportunity to pull all Clips because
I don't want to have to copyright strike
you but I'm appeasing to your wishes and
if you want to disrespectfully
um diss me on a video then I will
disrespectfully tell you that we will
copyright strike you if you do not
remove the videos
um and also guys we're re-uploading the
videos of Nick Fuentes and if you want
to see the full videos and see all of
the context go on to our Rumble that
link is in the description
um another instance that admin preach
did this is with fresh and fit so Abba
and preach tried to say that fresh and
fit laughs at a proud grapes Grapist
Charleston right but the reality is
he was talking about his past and why
people shouldn't take his path that's
what he was talking about on the on the
platform and and that's what they do
okay you can't you can have someone on
the show that's controversial that makes
made mistakes in the past
and if you get along with them if you're
kind to them if you're polite to them
they try to frame it like you believe
what you believe you support what they
support and these men that all they do
is react they've never brought on guests
they've never done a live in studio
um not well anyway to the point that
anyone knows who they are they they want
to tell us how to do it and honestly and
it's very hypocritical because Abba and
preach have laughed at grape jokes male
grape jokes and you know I could pull a
clip from there and do the YouTube
Bloodsport and paint them out a certain
way me personally when I see a girl with
like a nice booty I'm always like I like
you and I want you
and I'm gonna have you now I tell you
what I like you and I want you now we
can do this the easy way or we can do it
the hard way the choice is yours well I
don't think you and I will be doing
anything any kind of way okay I see you
choosing the hard way okay cut this
isn't working someone get this guy
hey that's disturbing
booty warrior I don't want to do that
but
and you know I understand there's always
going to be entertainment value I
understand that but it's just getting to
a point where we're starting to defame
people's characters and I'm just tired
of the lying I'm so tired of the lying
and the other thing that's insulting is
a lot of these reactors that are
pretending to stand up for my employees
are calling them slaves a colonial Manta
of pearl has people working on her
quote-unquote Plantation that's why
Pearl is a modern day female slave
master as if I am a slave master are you
crazy
oh my God are you nuts how insulting
it's like they're standing up for my
employees by calling them slaves what
the you guys are absolutely insane and
again all of these reactors have never
successfully had a YouTube show and they
want to tell us how to do their show and
it's like if I don't like the way a show
is run I just don't watch it but all
these reactors want to insert their
opinions and tell them how we should
have our conversations and in what way
we should have our conversations when
it's like you guys haven't done it
successfully most of you are small and
none of you have had a live show that's
like me telling you how to clip people
out of context I don't know how to do
that a lot of these YouTube channels
they do it to anyone that's bigger than
them
they're just looking for someone big
that they can tear down like look at
this business guy he did this [__] to
Kevin Samuels The Godfather of the
manosphere the problem you see the
problem with uh Kevin the perfume done
let me put y'all up on some manhood for
a moment here and some real facts
Because by the way he's still repeating
this garbage that the average male
weight has not increased since 1965. I
corrected him about that last year he's
still running around lying and talking
about men have only gained five pounds
since 1969 and women have gained 30
nonsense they both gained about the same
amount of weight according to the CDC
website and he's still lying because he
has a narrative that he wants to look
down on women about so he just lies
about things and none of y'all who claim
you were learning anything none of you
have ever called him up to correct him
and say hey dude I can't ride with you
telling outright lies to make your point
you can make a point but if you got a
lie to make a point it's not something
worth giving
and he he said that Kevin Samuels was
lying in order to tear down black women
do you know how disrespectful that is
and and in this clip MTR in this clip it
how hypocritical is it of you to say
that people should not have formed an
opinion on Kevin Samuels without
watching his full content but yet you
can make a reaction on me without
watching the full video what's happening
in the world today I think that with the
Advent may he you know rest in peace and
whatever you feel about him Kevin
Samuels who he made a whole living awful
going hard on us did you did you tune in
did you listen I never because I
wouldn't let that get in myself of
course my point is he had a lot of men
that I know and respect were following
him and listening to him I thought that
she was a journalist so as a journalist
she formed their opinion about somebody
that she didn't even watch his content I
mean she just said it meant that she
respect followed him so instead of
trying to understand why you set up a
false Narrative of him and rebuke him
from your life you simply and utterly
cannot make this [__] up modern women
today are conditioned not to care what
men think but are conditioned to only
hearing how awesome they are and that's
exactly why most cannot keep us this is
the other issue with O'Shea Duke Jackson
he he what he doesn't trust the
employees to know if they work for
someone
or sexist or that hates black women his
words his words and yet he thinks that
he knows when he doesn't even live in
this country he's never even interacted
with us O'Shea you've known King
Richie's for a couple years now why
didn't you sign him you care so much
about the black community and you're the
first to critique me but I did what you
didn't want to do why didn't you sign
him now he's having more success than
he's ever had and he's incredibly
talented and he's worked so incredibly
hard for that but you're the first one
to criticize me and call me names when I
did what you could have done and I did
what you could have done immediately I
I've only been you know YouTube famous
for maybe six months and then I I
started helping other people I started
signing Talent and I know you've got
your network I know you've got your mid
your very mid set but if you care so
much why didn't you do it an MTR what
you did to me in the thumbnail was
actually wrong that was so wrong stay
tuned for posting all the content that
MTR do not want us to post because we do
not care and you guys agreed to it and
you can't take back your consent and
also um MTR I'll expect the videos all
videos with me in it down within 48
hours because you do not want to
associate with my brand and I respect
that it's funny because what they're
doing to me is exactly what I was
talking about in this in the clip
they're using an atrocity to try to
guilt me and try to control me tell me
who I should have on my platform tell me
the way I should run my show tell me
that I am not good to my employees and
that is what these undercover feminists
do I like having people that disagree I
like having all different forms of
opinion and I will not apologize for
having somebody controversial on my
podcast you know I am more than willing
in the future and I would also like to
extend an invitation if somebody thinks
I'm misinformed um DM me let's get you
on the show tell me where I was wrong
and tell me who I should have on the
podcast to correct myself but it's one
thing when you want to correct me or say
something's inaccurate but it's another
thing when you go after my character to
everyone that thinks that I was wrong
for bringing Nick Fuentes on to everyone
that thinks I shouldn't be able to have
guests from the far right or the far
left to everyone that doesn't believe in
freedom of speech and bringing on
canceled people I'm one of the last
remaining platforms that still brings on
people that have been kicked off of all
platforms including YouTube and every
day we fight so hard against cancer
culture that we risk our entire platform
by having people on now it's crazy
because we have CNN BBC Piers Morgan
they have the most controversial guests
in the entire world on their show but
for some reason on YouTube you get
canceled for having controversial guests
on your platform and I'm young and I
still have a lot to learn and we're not
always going to get it right but here
are just pearly things we believe in
freedom of speech here at just pearly
things we believe in giving a platform
to those who have none and here at just
pearly things we are going to continue
to have controversial guests on again
and again
and to those of you that don't like it
you can kiss my ass